bien pues estamos en el problema número
9 así que vamos a ver qué dice tenemos
la ecuación 2 por x menos 3 esto es
igual a 7 y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale x ok pues tenemos una
ecuación
de primer grado esto es muy fácil de
resolver x menos 3 es lo mismo que es 7
entre dos pases de 2 dividiendo o
dividido entre 2 a x es igual a 7 entre
dos más tres pasos de tres del otro lado
y siete medios más tres es lo mismo que
7 entre 2 más 6 entre 2 lo cual es
3 entre 2 lo cual es
6.5 si lo queremos ver en su forma
decimal 6 enteros un medio o 13 medios
es lo mismo que 6.5 y esta es la
solución del problema número 9 así que
vamos a resolver el problema número 10 y
creo que me cabe aquí dice si pm
el punto p vive en la siguiente recta y
me dan la siguiente recta james menos 4
es igual a 3 por x menos 2 y me dicen si
hay p tiene como coordenada en x 4 ok
p es la forma 4 coma algo lo que me
falta justo es el valor de la coordenada
en lo que me preguntan es cuál es su
coordenada en este valor que va justo
aquí y bueno para esto lo que tenemos
que hacer es sustituir a x por 4 cuando
x vale 4
cuanto vale bien y bueno para eso voy a
utilizar esta ecuación de aquí voy a
utilizar que pep vive en esta recta y
entonces me va a quedar que y menos 4 es
igual a 3 por x pero equivale 4 en este
punto 4 - 2 y esto me queda que yo
24 es igual a 3 por
424 menos 2 esto de aquí es 22 por 13 66
y es igual a 64 a 64 porque voy a pasar
este del otro lado y esto me queda 10 es
decir que cuando x vale 4 vale 10 o
dicho de otra manera el punto p es el
punto 4,10 pero bueno no me preguntan
qué punto es el punto pues no puede su
coordinada en jeff y su coordenada en
que es 10 de lujo a problemas número 10
respuesta 10 vamos al siguiente problema
problema número 11 déjame borrar la
pantalla y vamos a trabajar con el
problema número 11 que dice lo siguiente
el auto récord de 60 kilómetros y gasta
un promedio de 1 litro de gasolina por
cada 20 kilómetros ok eso vamos a
juntarlo con este color el auto a el
auto am récord de 60 kilómetros recorre
60 kilómetros y él gasta un litro de
gasolina por cada 20 kilómetros es decir
a 20 kilómetros
por cada litro de gasolina o que recorre
20 kilómetros por cada litro de gasolina
después nos dicen que el auto ve el auto
ve gasta a un litro de gasolina por cada
15 kilómetros es decir que recorre 15
kilómetros 15 kilómetros por cada litro
de gasolina ok
cuántos kilómetros viaje el auto ven
cuando usa la misma cantidad de gasolina
que el auto para recorrer estos 60
kilómetros ok cuántos litros gasta el
auto a para recorrer estos 60 kilómetros
bueno si cada 20 kilómetros usa un litro
entonces tendríamos 20 40 60 esto quiere
decir que el auto a gas está en total
3 litros 3 litros y bueno si no me crees
lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera a
los litros 2 litros multiplicado por los
kilómetros entre litro entre el litro ok
esto es igual a pues esto con esteban
los kilómetros pero yo sé que recorrió
60 kilómetros y que va a un gasto de 20
kilómetros por litro aquí va 20 y lo que
necesitamos saber es la cantidad de
litros ok si despejamos a él m va a
quedar que es lo mismo que 60 entre 20
lo cual es 3 entonces gasta 3 litros
para recorrer estos 60 kilómetros y eso
para qué me sirve porque si ya sé que
gasta 3 litros entonces ve también va a
gastar 3 litros 3 litros porque me dice
que gasta la misma gasolina la misma
gasolina entonces pues usamos otra vez
esta misma ecuación de aquí tengo 3
litros por 15 kilómetros por litro esto
es lo mismo que 45 kilómetros utilizando
esta misma ecuación de aquí entonces me
va a recorrer 45 kilómetros lo que
recorre son 45
kilómetros con estos 3 litros de
gasolina ya está problema número 11 voy
a borrar esto de aquí vamos el problema
número 12 espera déjenme poner otra capa
problema número 12 y por cierto tienen
una figura parecida a ésta tengo aquí
una recta ok tengo por aquí el punto am
por aquí está el punto b por aquí tengo
el punto c y por aquí tengo el punto de
no no abc de ok y me dicen que
deja de cambiar de color este ángulo
vale 65 grados 65 grados este de aquí
vale 100 grados este aquí vale 100
grados ok este vale 120 grados
120 grados este ángulo vale x por cierto
este es el punto este es el punto d este
es el punto c este es el punto d y aquí
tengo el punto
y lo que me preguntan esencialmente es
cuánto vale x ahora para sacar el valor
de x
necesitamos forzosamente encontrar el
valor de este ángulo que le voy a poner
bien le voy a poner bien porque x es
suplementario y tiempo es decir que la
suma de estos dos la suma de este más
éste me deben de dar 180 grados ahora
aquí tengo un cuadrilátero y tú sabes
cuánto suman los ángulos de un
cuadrilátero
bueno pues suman 360 grados y no me
crees pues qué te parece si lo probamos
de aquí acá voy a hacer una línea y
tengo dos triángulos y si tengo dos
triángulos tú si me puedes decir cuánto
vale la suma de este ángulo de esto no
espera déjame cambiar de herramienta de
este ángulo de aquí de este de aquí más
este de aquí más este de aquí
la suma de estos me da 180 grados porque
están adentro de un triángulo ahora qué
te parece si me fijo en este de aquí
déjame cambiar de color en este de aquí
más este de aquí más estoy aquí también
está dentro de un triángulo por lo tanto
la suma de todos estos tres ángulos me
debe de dar 180 grados eso quiere decir
que si tengo un cuadrilátero cualquier
cuadrilátero debe de sumar en ángulos
360 grados la suma de éste de este de
este y de este bien debe de dar 360
grados ok entonces lo voy a poner justo
aquí antes de que se nos olvide 360
grados pero yo quiero encontrar el valor
de jeff entonces a esto le voy a quitar
65 grados que es este de aquí ya esto le
voy a quitar 100 grados que es este de
aquí ya este le voy a quitar 120 grados
que es este de aquí y con esto voy a
poder obtener el valor de 10 es decir
que ye más 120 grados más 100 grados más
65 grados es 360 grados es justo lo que
estoy diciendo y cuánto es 360 menos 65
menos 100 menos 120 bueno me queda 260
am 200
95 95 20 es 75 75 grados
el valor de ok de lujo y para qué
queríamos james hace claro porque quién
es este de aquí y llevarles 75 grados y
la suma de todos estos valen 360 grados
pero yo quiero saber el valor de x de
este clip de x grados y bueno yo sé que
x grados massieu grados es igual a 180
grados porque son ángulos suplementarios
la suma de ellos dos me da 180 grados es
decir que x grados es igual a 180 grados
menos 75 grados y bueno de aquí ya es
muy fácil x es igual a
105 grados que es la respuesta de este
problema el valor de x es 105 grados y
lo obtuvimos dándonos cuenta que las
sumas de todos los ángulos internos de
cualquier cuadrilátero son 360 grados ok
vamos el problema número 13 déjame ver
la pantalla y vámonos el problema número
13 que me dice lo siguiente
el primer término de una sucesión es 20
entonces empezamos con 20 y el segundo
término es porque ok
y dice el tercer término y los
siguientes se encuentran sacando el
promedio de los dos términos anteriores
ok por ejemplo el siguiente término
sería ocho más veinte entre dos lo cual
es 28 entre 2 lo cual es
14 aunque mi siguiente términos 14 y así
no puedo seguir seguir cuál es el valor
del primer término de la sucesión que no
es un entero aunque pues vamos a seguir
sacando términos hasta que lleguemos a 1
el cual nos entero el que sigue sería
este más este entre 214 más 8 entre 2
esto es lo mismo que 22 entre dos lo
cual es 11 y jajaja ya encontré el
primero que no es entero porque este es
11 éste es 11 cuando yo le sume 14 14
más 11 ya esto lo divide entre 2 esto no
me va a dar un número pero esto es lo
mismo que a 25 entre 2 lo cual por
cierto es un
12.5
12.5 que este este si no es un número
entero de hecho es un número racional
por lo tanto la respuesta es 12.5 y tu
llenas tu caja en blanco con
12.5 problema número 13 creo que aquí me
cabe el problema número 14 que dice lo
siguiente a si x es igual a un quinto y
dya x es igual a un quinto de jeff ok y
por otra parte me dicen que es tres
décimos de z y es igual a 3 sobre 10 de
z y además me dicen que zetas mayor que
0 z es más grande que 0 ok eso es
importante lo que me preguntan es que
fracciones x dz
y bueno esencialmente lo que yo quiero
saber es cuánto vale x en términos de z
y para eso puedes sustituir el valor de
esta y justo aquí aquí me dice que voy a
utilizar alguien pero que vale 13 está
entonces lo puedo poner justo aquí es
decir que si nosotros empezamos con que
x es igual a un quinto de bien pero vale
3 decimos de zeta entonces me quedaría
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que un
quinto por a y aquí voy a utilizar esta
ecuación por tres décimos de z pero aquí
tengo una multiplicación de quebrados
hizo eso si desea hacer x es igual a 1
por 3 es 35 x 1050
z dicho de otra manera x visto como una
fracción de z es 3 entre 50 o 350 vos dz
y es justo mi respuesta tú pones 3 entre
50 y te van a poner una respuesta
correcta justo esto de aquí y bueno
también es tan fácil el problema número
14 vamos a hacer problema número 15
déjame ver si me da tiempo
no creo que tengo cosas que hacer
mejor hacemos el problema número 15 en
el siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima